but you know the brand undefeated yeah
they did their own take on it and it
looks F they cool and their GES are sick
as F did you take notes for your own
gym he's on what gy what you
[Music]
forgot all right so I think it's time we
talk about better Boba have you guys
heard about that no was that is that is
that our competition all right [__] them
it's not your competition okay okay
what's better Boba that's a company it's
a company that's kind of being
scrutinized right now did you guys hear
about better Boba they have healthy Boba
so yeah so it's a Portland based company
it's owned by I believe she's white like
a white lady and her Indian husband and
they've created this like Boba recipe
that they it's it's almost like it's
it's to be assumed that it's superior to
the normal B why is it carbless is it
just it's not carbless but what they're
saying is that it's all natural
ingredients it's only four ingredients
no child labor
I yet to be determined that's how you
get the ball so small you got the little
kids doing the balls every day yeah
obviously this topic is the darling of
next shark they freaking love hating on
it but then um it's one of those things
where like I think it's been
misunderstood slightly I will say okay
because they're trying to improve
packaged readymade Boba that you order
and then you just like put it in your
drink they're trying to improve that by
making it better because the ones that I
think that you can get now kind of
preservatives yeah and they said that
when they they tried it they didn't
think it was good but they're getting
huge amounts of hate and like you know
for appropriating B gentrifying it God
that whole thing's kind of happening I
agree with that you agree okay let's
hear from someone who agrees Well it
Well for like Boba don't you just if you
want to make it at home don't you just
put in a pot and just boil it Boba is
very annoying to make it at home I've
tried it's the ready one so it's already
squishy it's not the hard one it's the
squishy one have you guys seen this the
the you could get these already like
already cooked yeah like they're in a
that seems sketchy to me huh it looks
like it looks like these it's just like
in a plastic sack but you can just put
it in your drink right away and drink it
or you have to cook I don't know if you
have to cook it oh no you have to cook
those they just need the Indian husband
to be the face of the no they tried they
tried like they try to list it as like
oh it's woman and minority owned that's
how they're calling it so that you don't
think it's you know she should have
married asan trying to soften the blow a
little bit but they're getting a ton of
ha you know what the public sentiment is
is probably both of y'all don't know
[__] about Boba so shut the [__] up that
is yeah that's the general consensus but
they did respond to the hate and I
thought they did a really nice response
what did they say we do know [__] about
Boba you shut the [__]
up like oh [__] you're right they're
like maybe if you made your Boba right
to begin with we wouldn't have to make
this comp 10 toes on oura yeah they just
bang on people if it was good like I
wouldn't care if if they if it was
shitty then i' would be like you know
what yep like Chick-fil-A they're the
best example of like like the [__]
egg rolls at Jack in the
who who who hold on Avocado no what you
say remember when Chick-fil-A came out
everyone was mad at them cuz they just
didn't like gay people you know what I
mean they still maintain that they still
maintain it still you see dude there's
always a [__] line it's true cuz then
the one in West Hollywood should not be
that banging and it is and it is banging
bro it is banging yeah they'll be like I
[__] hate that I love these
sandwiches yeah yeah yeah I bet that's a
thing I bet that's a combo do you guys
feel like like as Asians there's any
kind of gatekeeping that can be done
when someone like I don't give a [__]
yeah I I I agree with with that I don't
really care if it's a white lady making
it I think it's I'm a very like um what
is that word don't give a [__] no met
like a [__] like it starts with if
it's just good or not has to be yeah
yeah yeah it's more like quality if it's
like I don't care what your race is or
who's backing the product it's like did
you make a quality product and what I
will say cuz this reminds me of this
other one I've seen a a lady make a
healthy chamoy cuz chamoy has a lot of
preservative sugar free one right yeah
it's I don't know if it was sugar free
but it was like not using artificial
dyes like red 40 and [__] like red 40 is
like quite literally poison red 40 is
good man she drinks red 40 she would
have a red 40 IV if she could so is
pretty [__] bomb though it tastes
great and it's like cultural right so
somebody made like a healthy version I I
also think food is like uh especially in
our culture in American and stuff fusion
with food happens so frequently that
like it's hard to gatekeep like food
because that's just like ingredient that
ends up being put into like some other
[__] cultures this and that but
gatekeeping maybe like very very
specific like cultural Traditions or or
garbs or something like that I think is
but do you think that is do you guys
think there's a little bit of a almost
like they walked right into it by
calling it better Boba a little bit
people are nitpicking though bro but I
think they're talking about better Boba
as in like it's healthier that is what
they're talking about exactly but
they're not trying to say like oh we did
it better than the white people's bu was
better than they were like we didn't
mean that it was Superior we meant that
the ingredients are better for you they
shouldn't have used they should have
said white Boba objectively that's just
a good name agree alliteration yeah
better Boba and it and it's so many bees
it's such a good brand I agree I think
that and it's like weird to consider it
like whitewashing to make something
healthy like why do white people own
healthify that's true it feels almost
like backwards like racism to yourself
like oh you're trying to make my [__]
healthy keep your white [__] out of here
like her husband the other owner is
Indian right Asian boom no no they tried
that he said and they were like n you
would have thought wrong called them
minority not Asian different so like
let's say that there's like some some
white frat dude that makes a competitor
and it's called better Seltzer and it's
just all your same I mean better be good
if you're going to put that title yeah
but it's all Asian flavors the same [__]
something so so there's a guy that makes
sake soda he's a white guy oh it's not
bad tasting but like it is like he makes
similar content to Jeremy like you know
and it's like but but again like um I
don't know I I don't really hold that
against him either like in my opinion
like you're just a human being trying to
make it you know and I just start with
if it's good or not exactly like even
recently um I don't know if youself but
like Nike just came out with the whole
weight set and I was like that's [__]
whack that's the first thing I've ever
seen Nike do where I was like ball on
what the is it because it's not
Innovative wait what is the weight set
so they like dumbbells and stuff so I
think Nike is moving into like the
strength and conditioning space they've
always done running basketball you know
Street Wear all that stuff Nike SB
skateboarding and all that and so like
they I think want to tap into to
weightlifting and they come out with a
Nike dumbbell set or whatever and so you
would think that Nike would do something
at the Nike level but as soon as they
came in it just looked very very average
so to me it's not even about like so the
product sucked yeah it wasn't about like
oh cool are they going to do uh I mean
Nike is making these products first my
first and foremost is is it good or not
so did you go like stick to running no I
just saw it I was like damn I'm a big
fan of Nike to is it because you expect
Innovation from them [__] yeah I mean
with all that money you would expect
yeah I I thought it was going to be next
level blow my mind you know what would
be a next level blow your mind weight
set like the weight design have you seen
the undefeated gym in KT that place is
cool that oh yeah The Undefeated
jiujitsu one like what do they have the
aesthetic of it I I'll show you after
but the aesthetic of it is insane you're
like I've never seen a gym or Jiu-Jitsu
gym but that's not like entry level
enough for like the consumer base that
they have wait it's like a weightlifting
gym yeah there's like a weightlifting SL
uh Jiu-Jitsu JY and what's what's this
place called um it's called undefeated
like u a TCP or something but you know
the brand undefeated yeah they did their
own take on it and it looks [__] and
their GES are sick as [__] did you take
notes for your own
gym he's on what gym whaty he forgot he
forgot no they already did a way too
cool I was like we can't we can't beat
that the jky cool man we should have a
jby gym powered by matcha you got you
got to talk to Jeremy matcha pre-workout
oh just direct comp just better
gym better undefeated gym Jeremy giv the
best advice that's so like if that Boba
is not even good then you give people a
way to nitpick at what you're doing yeah
yeah yeah that's true and I think most
people who are hating on it obviously
hav't TR and if that's what you Market
it too if you Market it as better Boba
it better be better Boba do you have
time to hate on something like this get
another job you're a loser get three
jobs like be busy I feel like no busy is
ever hating yeah that's true that's true
there's there's [__] I see where in my
head I'm like this is [__] stupid but
I just don't have the energy to be like
I hate this I don't care I don't
understand Asians that see this and feel
threatened that their cultur is being
destroyed you know what I mean like
there's a lot more things destroying
Asian culture like [__] child
soldiers and militant terrorist groups
and you know like like all white
stealing our Asian girl godamn yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah let's talk about one
issue let's talk about that no man Boba
still here to that but the but the thing
they get outraged and need to [__]
write articles about is a [__] Indian
guy making Boba these are the
[__] that play valerant 24
hours a day [__] them just a quick disc
just a random quick disc the Nerds are
what they're is it usually the Asians
that are saying all oh it's all Asian
yeah just go in next shark comments
you'll usually see me there roasting the
commenters but that's you see him in
every comment report a lot of them
talking [__] to everybody yeah quite
good at it what's that word for them
like the liberal Boba Asians Boba
liberals that just yeah Boba liberals
there we go there's a lot of [__]
Asian [__] out there though I agree I
I think there's too many of us that are
too soft and there's Boba conservative
what's Boba conservative conserv Boba
conservative is like the it's like the
other side of of the Boba liberal but
there's still Boba yeah why it got to be
Boba dude and then what's Boba
preservative I feel like that has to be
a different food item that's like
pecking I love Boba I don't know why
make it pecking dog dude yeah something
something like hard and manly like they
killed something so Boba liberal is like
the stereotypical NorCal like upper
middle class Asian dude that's woke
about everything what about shom B
conservatives oh that's nice they're
from they're from China and they're
they're usually they don't care about
America tapak conservative that's the
Boba conservative is the like the one
that's like so freaking right-wing that
they're almost like oh I wish I was born
W you know like that kind
of yeah that's that's my of table that's
[__] ridiculous I see myself in the
miror and I go W China man I wish they
were bigger like that I wish they were
bigger rinkle godamn it I do like the
Boba conservative better me too what
about the ones that use their [__]
phone as a what about this what you have
to say about this huh look at that what
did you do put a cookie on the phone
yeah I don't know what they're tripping
about
FES of bub call
[Music]
me